[Music]
what's up mkbhd here and welcome to your
very first look and my first impressions
of the samsung galaxy note 20 and note
20 ultra so samsung's unpacked event is
today there's a lot of stuff being
announced today and we'll get to all of
it eventually but we're going to cover
the two main new things which are the
two new flagship phones and here
they are and as you can see they look
just like the leaks you might have seen
some of those two huge phones this is
that bronze color that they're in here
and they have a lot of the same dna as
notes of the past in both design and
feature set but there is a lot of new
stuff here and since there are two new
phones i'm going to start with the note
20 ultra because that's where a lot of
the sweet interesting new features are
so let me just get the specs out of the
way right off the top because that's the
easiest part to take in so they're
top-notch snapdragon 865 plus
up to 12 gigs of ram at 256 gigs of
storage and that's still expandable via
a micro sd card slot up top that's still
pretty rare and there's a 4 500 milliamp
hour battery inside a triple camera
array which we'll get to in a second
and a huge huge
6.9 inch 1440p 120 hertz amoled display
with that little selfie camera hole
punch cut out in the middle up top there
it is a bit of a curved display over the
edges which i personally wish we'd stop
seeing but there's no denying even from
my limited hands-on time with it this is
probably one of the best displays in any
smartphone and of course we'll know
better once we have it in hand for a
longer time for the full review but hey
that's what we expect at this point from
galaxy note i mean just look at this
thing but one big asterisk though is
even for the steep price of i haven't
told you yet but this phone starts at 1
300
even for all that money you still just
like s20 ultra can't use it at its
highest frame rate and highest
resolution
at the same time so sure enough if you
dig into the display settings any fine
motion smoothing is 1080p out the box so
there's either standard 60 hertz or
adaptive so you can't lock it at 120
hertz but it will move between 120 and
60 depending on what's happening on the
phone but if you go into resolution and
switch from 1080p up to 1440p it tells
you this doesn't allow for adaptive
higher fresh rates so i guess i will be
rocking this phone again at 1080p and
120 hertz because those extra frames
look better than the extra pixels
overall though i'm a fan of the note 20
ultra design just looking at it it still
feels boxy in my hand the way i like it
the bezels look impossibly thin and
overall the aesthetic with the matte
bezels
and satin finish on the back just it
screams premium i mean you look at this
thing and you can tell you feel it it's
premium glass and metal from top to
bottom it's great
but then let's check out this camera
bump so the rounded rectangle housing
the triple cameras and the galaxy note
20 ultra is absolutely massive i wish i
had measured it when i was here with the
limited hands on time just to see
exactly how big it is but it's huge just
like the s20 ultra and i think it even
looks bigger because it's just on one
giant raised slab rectangle instead of
like the s20 ultra's double stepped
curved slab basically it's a really
pronounced defining feature of this
phone's design and it's funny i actually
kind of started naturally holding the
phone up from the back by propping my
finger under the huge ledge that the
camera makes because the phone is so big
but anyway inside this bump you have the
main camera suite you'd expect with the
standard ultra wide and telephoto and
this time in the note 20 ultra the
telephoto lens is in fact a periscope
lens nested sideways in the phone
allowing you 5x optical zoom and up to a
50x space zoom
not quite the 100x that they printed on
the back of the galaxy s20 ultra but i
think samsung realizes that was a
mistake and i think we're all okay with
maxing out at 50x as long as the quality
of the zoom we actually want like 3x and
5 and 10x are actually better and it
seems to be but of course that will have
to be tested for the full review they
also kept 8k video from the s20 ultra
and added a few different aspect ratios
but it's worth noting that all of them
will shoot from the 64 megapixel
telephoto camera not the main camera
still so there is still going to be a
crop if you shoot in 8k in case you were
wondering but of course this wouldn't be
a galaxy note if we didn't have
that s pen which is moved over to the
left side of the phone and this year the
s pen makes one particularly huge leap
forward
and that's in latency so latency is the
delay between when you actually touch
the screen and when there's actually a
register on the screen for what you just
did
and so the latency of the s pen was up
at around 42 milliseconds all the way up
to the last generation
and with the note 20 ultra they've
gotten it down to
nine milliseconds so
about a fifth of the time and you can
definitely feel the difference you can
see the difference so the s pen has now
arrived at apple pencil levels of
responsiveness in fact it's matched that
nine millisecond number so there's
really zero perceptible gap between the
pen
and what i'm actually writing so it
feels like i'm basically writing or
painting directly onto the display which
is awesome and this is great for
frequent s pen users not just for
writing text but even for maneuvering
around the ui with a pen like i have for
years
and that combined with a lot of the
other subtle samsung notes usability
improvements and feature enhancements
and things like that just feels like a
great update for galaxy note for those
who rely on this accessory so that's
note 20 ultra and again that's that's
the ultra premium super high end
flagship 12.99 like we said kind of the
opposite of the pixel 4a i just reviewed
but then of course there's also now
the note 20
which to me
is a little more confusing and that's
because when you look at it on paper and
with all the different things that note
20 cuts down for note 20 ultra and
there's a lot uh you would think oh this
is going to be a significantly less
expensive phone to be a more accessible
cheaper note to get people hooked on the
s pen and then want them to get the
ultra later but the note 20 still starts
at
9.99 so picking it up for the first time
you may not immediately notice a lot of
those cut downs it's still got that
bronze look it actually has even more of
a soft textured finish on the back and
it's a little bit lighter than the ultra
but that lightness
is because it's a plastic back
not glass so that's number one then the
display up front here it still looks
great as you can tell still has the
little hole punch cut out still has
great brightness and color but it's now
a slightly smaller 6.7 inches
and it's flat which i actually like it
really locks in the phone's boxy shape
even more than the rounded note 20 ultra
but it also now has a slightly larger
hole punch cutout
and slightly bigger bezels all the way
around and it's now 1080p
and 60 hertz and then you get to the
specs and they're again almost the same
snapdragon 865 plus is still there but
it now maxes out at eight gigs of ram
and 128 gigs of storage but it also now
doesn't have expandable storage like the
ultra does so that 128 is your absolute
max
then the new s pen again it's still here
but with not quite the same blazing fast
nine millisecond latency instead it cuts
it down to 26 milliseconds still really
fast and nice to see an improvement of
about 50 percent but
yeah not the same as the ultra and it's
also a slightly smaller 4300 milliamp
hour battery instead of 4500 and the
camera system maxes out at 30x zoom
instead of 50x which again is not really
that big of a deal but it's because the
note 20 doesn't use a periscope camera
like the ultra does it's just a standard
3x telephoto shooter which is why the
camera bump also isn't as massive here
basically the note 20 is to the note 20
ultra
what the s20 is to the s20 ultra it's a
slightly smaller
slightly less premium flagship in its
own right with a few cut downs from the
ultra premium stuff that most people
hopefully won't notice and i think this
is mostly a good idea like the the cut
down from what the 30x versus 50x zoom
who really cares that much uh the 26
millisecond to 9 millisecond response
time again i had limited hands-on time
with them but i actually didn't really
notice that big of a difference either
they're both very responsive but there's
something about asking a thousand bucks
for
a 1080p
60 hertz
plastic phone
with
128 gigs of non-expandable storage tops
like just some of that doesn't feel
quite up to the money i'm gonna say that
in the first time in the notes history
that this note 20
is a bit overpriced i think you can
straight up get better phones for a
thousand bucks or get equivalent phones
for less like this isn't my review but i
think there's going to be people cross
shopping in a store who will see note 20
for a thousand bucks and then we'll see
galaxy s20 next to it or oneplus 8 pro
next to it phones that cost less money
that feel like they actually give you
more i think the one reason you would
get the note 20 is because the s pen is
still pretty unrivaled in this
smartphone world as far as premium
stylist experiences and some people will
want that and i think samsung knows that
and there's also still samsung note
stuff and some note exclusive stuff like
dex wireless so if you remember what dex
could do on a desktop display you don't
need an adapter for it anymore or a
special cable it does it wirelessly via
miracast that stuff's really impressive
but i guess i'm just curious how many
people are going to want that stuff
versus who will just go turn around and
buy an s20 or something cheaper instead
but i'm curious what you think let me
know in the comments below and what you
think of note 20 versus note 20 ultra
and them existing at the same time and
if you haven't already subscribed for
the full review definitely make sure to
do that so you're among the first to see
it also
and until then thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace